I heard something today and I'm not sure
it's true that your first name that you
were named after the Little Mermaid yes
is that true yeah what's actually really
funny is I have to be honest with you I
had no idea what I was named after until
I called my dad backstage just now and I
was like hey you know kind of worried
that maybe someones can ask me if I was
named after Little Mermaid never really
told me and he was like yeah we named
you after the Little Mermaid but what we
never knew is if your name was Arielle
Arielle Arielle so it was kind of like
we don't know the inflection of it but I
am named after the little mother so
first of all I think it's nice because
people love that movie I can relate to
it because people always thought that I
was named after Conan the Barbarian
seriously they real went out and it got
me in a lot of trouble because when I
was a kid people like Golding whiz you
sword and you know in the Boston area
they then beat you but I my parents
didn't know about Conan the Barbarian
they just heard it was a cool old like
Celtic name so and it works this is it
so name so people don't have to know
it's a beautiful name well thank you
yeah you're happy with it right I love
it all right
you